gelbe westen stehen für ich spreche
englisch
orangefarbene für ukrainisch und
russisch beide bedeuten ich helfe dir
seit zwei wochen organisieren die
freiwilligen schon die hilfe am berliner
hauptbahnhof wo jeden tag mehr menschen
aus der ukraine ankommen helfer wie
janosch
stündlich kommen hier neue züge an wie
man weiter kommt in deutschland in
berlin wir weisen die leute wo es zu
essen wir trinken hygieneartikel sie
haben ein still zelt aufgebaut und eine
ecke für kinder eine stolze starke
ukrainerin hat angelina geflohen aus
apple hier gemalt
stolz und stark wie nadia selbst erst
vor ein paar wochen aus odessa
geflüchtet hilft sie nun hier jeden tag
ich bin gesund ich bin ja ich bin
ukraine ich kann nichts als ja in meinem
land ist es ja diese situation aber ich
bin nicht durch linie ja ich möchte
nicht hier bleiben nach meiner land
gehen und dann helfen zu meinem land
jetzt hilft sie aber zuerst hier erklärt
anderen ukrainerinnen wie es weitergeht
erklärt ihnen das fremde deutschland
eigentlich sollten heute busse menschen
weiter nach hannover bringen aber sie
kamen nicht nur müssen die freiwilligen
improvisieren und organisieren die
weiterreise mit dem zu
also wir uns einen anderen plan überlegt
wir haben es mit den freiwilligen
hannover hauptbahnhof in verbindung
gesetzt und organisiert dass sie die
menschen am hauptbahnhof abholen und in
die messe bringen wo sie in die
unterkunft wo der bus eigentlich
entfallen sollte mascha nadia janosch
sie machen das alle hier in ihrer
freizeit oft 16 stunden am tag ohne
pause
unsere arbeitgeber sind nicht der bund
oder der senat oder sonst was diese
menschen und wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass sie wenigstens
irgendwie das gefühl haben dass sie hier
nicht unerwünscht sind nachdem sie so
eine lange reise hinter sich für die
freiwilligen manchmal kaum noch zu
schaffen so viele menschen die ihre
hilfe brauchen würde kinder mit ihren
mamas tage lang sind sie gereist und
müssen sich nun zu recht finden
geht nicht wir brauchen hilfe
irina ist in der ukraine geboren hilft
hier jeden tag schlafen kann sie sowieso
nicht mehr
inzwischen ist es abend geworden statt
menschen aus berlin weiter im land zu
verteilen kommen hier immer mehr neue
busse an
wir haben aber zunehmend probleme mit
bussen die nachts kommen also
tatsächlich haben wir auf
unkontrollierte ukrainische busfahrer
die hier einfach ansteuern nachts die
hier ankommen mit teilweise auch wieder
über hunderten personen
und dann hier sind allerdings ist ja
auch die sicherheitslage so dass wir
hier super viele menschen auch über
nacht trotzdem haben also unabhängig von
dem zuwachs von personen haben wir
grundsätzlich hier super viele personen
auch nachts im bahnhof lehramtsstudentin
katja hilft hier seit einer woche sie
übernimmt heute die nachtschicht und
damit auch viel verantwortung nacht sind
sie weniger und in den letzten tagen
haben männer mehrfach versucht junge
frauen zum mitkommen zu überreden
was sich heute nicht mehr aufklären
lässt der mann wurde nicht gefasst nur
gesehen
natürlich geflüchtet menschen haben und
da hatten wir schon ein zwei große
konfliktsituationen inzwischen ist mehr
polizei und bvg sicherheit vor ort das
beruhigt ein wenig trotzdem privatzimmer
vermitteln sie hier gerade nicht mehr
weiter so groß die sorge dass etwas
passiert
diese familie würde gerne menschen
aufnehmen
[Musik]
so zeigt katja der familie wie sie ihr
zimmer online zur verfügung stellen
können damit organisationen es
überprüfen und weitervermitteln können
trotzdem ein riesen dilemma
angeboten werden was der anderen seite
ist es eigentlich das einzige brücke
systems direkt funktioniert dass leute
unterkommen können wir auf den
offiziellen webseiten überhaupt nichts
funktioniert danach checkt katja die
lage in der umfunktionierten speise
halle sind alle versorgt läuft alles
reibungslos
einen kurzen schluck trinken
dann geht es weiter
zwar gibt es inzwischen auch hilfe vom
senat wie das catering und ein wärmezelt
draußen doch noch immer sind die
freiwilligen hier erste anlaufstation
für alles
vor allem wenn um mitternacht noch neue
züge kommen
vor allem schlafplätze werden jetzt
gebraucht weil immer noch menschen
ankommen für diese dreifach mama mit
baby haben sie heute nacht ein
kostenloses hotel gefunden andere kommen
in diesem schlaf zug unter zumindest
eine nacht ausholen in ruhe und frieden
[Musik]